[Music]
what do you know about the american
civil war
just saying these words the civil war
probably brings some familiar images to
mind
northern soldiers in union blue marching
against southern troops in confederate
grey
epic battles at shiloh and gettysburg
abraham lincoln's emancipation
proclamation in the end of slavery
the victory of the union over the
confederacy but there's something else
you should know about that era
something that ties these events
together and that you probably didn't
learn in school
the civil war was also america's
greatest left-wing revolution
here's how in the early 19th century
african slavery was the foundation of
social and economic life in the american
south
millions of black workers were owned as
property by wealthy planters
who denied them education controlled
their family lives
and reaped the fruits of their labor
this system was wildly profitable and
the wealth it produced
allowed a tiny elite to dominate
southern and national politics
and before the civil war it was
expanding all across the western
hemisphere
in 1860 between the united states brazil
and cuba
there were more enslaved people than
ever before for years
a small group of american abolitionists
had denounced slavery as an abomination
these radical activists were scorned by
much of society and ignored by both the
two mainstream political parties but in
the 1850s as slaveholders tried to
extend slavery across the west
their opponents made a breakthrough the
old two-party system melted down and the
new republican party won massive
northern support
by opposing slavery's expansion while
putting bondage itself
on a road to ultimate extinction the
abolitionists broke through
in part because they named the slave
power
as the oppressive ruling class that it
was they pointed out that slaveholders
were just one percent of the population
but somehow controlled every branch of
government they argued that black
bondage was not just morally wrong
but a threat to free labor everywhere
the struggle between anti-slavery and
slavery said abraham lincoln
was part of the eternal struggle between
the common right of humanity
and the divine right of kings the same
spirit that says
you toil and work and earn bread and
i'll eat it
it was the common worker black or white
against the rich
these populist assaults on the ruling
class helped lincoln's party win the
election of 1860.
contemporaries called it a political
revolution
its threat to slaveholders was so
serious that they formed their own
separate republic
the confederate states of america in the
civil war that followed the stakes were
clear
the union fought against human bondage
for a democratic majority
and for the dignity of all labor the
confederacy fought to preserve
bondage and elite rule confederates
fought as lincoln told congress in 1862
to put capital that's wealth measured in
human beings
above labor in the structure of
government enslaved laborers understood
these stakes
hundreds of thousands fled to union
lines even before emancipation was
proclaimed
radical abolitionists knew it too
frederick douglass barnstormed the
country rousing black men to enlist in
the union army by war's end around 200
000 black soldiers and sailors had taken
up
arms to crush the rebellion the cause of
the union was the cause of the
international left
while conservative aristocrats and
capitalists in europe sympathize with
the confederacy
radicals and labor organizations
supported the union in 1864 a german
journalist named karl marx
declared that the american anti-slavery
war would launch a new era of ascendancy
for the working class
emancipation as marx understood was not
a middle-class reform project
it was a true social revolution only in
the united states and in haiti
was emancipation sudden uncompensated
and enforced by former slaves themselves
that revolution remains incomplete after
the war former slaves and radical
republicans
were defeated by what the scholar w e b
du bois calls a counter-revolution of
property
led by former slaveholders and
conservative businessmen
under the terror of jim crow segregation
many of the civil war's victories for
labor and for democracy were rolled back
but not all the destruction of american
shadow slavery was a historic and
enduring victory
it meant that black southerners were
able to create the schools and the
churches
that ceded their later fight against jim
crow it radically expanded american
democracy
and made the modern labor and civil
rights movements possible
the civil war was america's greatest
left-wing revolution
even now its work remains unfinished but
every left-wing struggle
for the rule of democratic majorities
for the rights of labor over property
and for meaningful freedom and equality
can claim its legacy
i'm matt carp associate professor of
history at princeton university
for the gravel institute
[Music]
thank you for watching this video if you
believe in our mission please consider
becoming a patron of the institute
or making a one-time contribution
[Music]
you